Looking back at the weirdest and riskiest
movies of 2019, some were fantastic, and others
just didn't work.
Either way, these films featured plots that
left viewers scratching their heads.
Here are some of the most baffling movies
of 2019.
Heads up - some light spoilers ahead.
Writer-director Ari Aster's Midsommar avoids
many horror tropes to tell its tale of folk
horror - and Florence Pugh is nothing short
of a powerhouse in the lead role.
Midsommar is one of those films where you
can tell things are going to go majorly sideways
from the beginning.
Aster loves to leave dangling threads for
his characters - and his audience - to pull
on, with lots of half-answers sprinkled throughout.
"That sounds fun."
Regardless of what your theories about the
movie might be, there are most likely clues
to support them - and plenty of clues that
point in the opposite direction.
Velvet Buzzsaw is one of those movies that
makes it tough to truly tell whether what
you're watching is actually any good.
It has all the pieces in place, starting with
a solid cast lead by Jake Gyllenhaal and Rene Russo.
Dan Gilroy directed it, fresh off the dark
and grossly satisfying Nightcrawler.
It centers around artwork coming to life and
murdering critics - and that basically sums
things up.
On the other hand, is anything in Velvet Buzzsaw
really happening?
Or is it all just an extremely meta commentary
on the way we consume and critique art?
What's even going on in this movie?
There are a lot of questions raised and not
a lot of answers given.
But if you like watching good actors playing
bizarre characters, Velvet Buzzsaw is for
Very few directors have debuted with their first feature quite like Jordan Peele did
with 2017's Get Out.
He had high hopes to live up to with his sophomore
effort, Us, and he delivered another fresh
thriller with a ton of layers.
"If you wanna get crazy we can get crazy."
It didn't quite strike the same nerve as Get
Out, but it inspired plenty of hot takes on
its release.
Everyone in the main cast plays a double role
in the film - their regular selves and their
"Tethered" version, unleashed from the secret
underground society where they've been kept
for who knows how long.
As the film goes on and you learn more about
what the Tethered are, it becomes apparent
why they're a force to be reckoned with.
Lupita Nyong'o steals the show, delivering
an impressive dual performance.
Even after you've seen it multiple times,
Us will keep you guessing and have you theorizing
for hours.
Robert Eggers followed up his 2015 film The
Witch with 2019's equally perplexing The Lighthouse.
It's shot in black and white and an almost
square aspect ratio - no widescreen here.
It's a two-man show, with Robert Pattinson
and Willem Dafoe playing two men manning a
lighthouse together - and it's completely
bizarre.
When you watch The Lighthouse, there are about
50 different ways to interpret it.
Maybe everything is literally happening.
Maybe only some of it is.
Maybe Pattinson isn't real.
Maybe Dafoe isn't!
Unlike The Witch, The Lighthouse never really
gives you any answers.
Still, it's an impressive film that a group
of people could watch at the same time and
all come to wildly different, plausible conclusions.
The Perfection is a body-horror masterpiece
that will have you squirming in your seat.
It's also a film that will keep you guessing
until the very end, even if things do wrap
up a little more neatly than many of 2019's
weirdest films.
The plot centers around two women in a prestigious
music academy.
What starts as a simple tale of revenge becomes
more and more insane - it's exploitative and
tough to watch, but it definitely hits the
right buttons for people who are looking for
a bizarre viewing experience.
"Something is wrong.
Something is wrong with me."
Featuring killer performances from both Allison
Williams and Logan Browning, The Perfection
is creepy, weird, and oddly satisfying.
One of the best films of 2019 is also one
of its most baffling.
Legendary Korean director Bong Joon-Ho's Parasite
is full of twists and turns, and you never
quite know exactly where it's going.
The film starts out as a commentary on wealth
and social class and a story in which one
lower-class family begins to push themselves
into the life and social standing of a much
wealthier family.
About halfway through, however, things take
a dramatic turn and Parasite becomes more
of a horror-thriller as secrets are revealed
and a series of dramatic revelations occur.
Joon-ho employs dark humor so perfectly that
it keeps you off balance.
While watching Parasite, you never know if
you should be smiling or just plain horrified.
Not every baffling movie of 2019 was good,
and Serenity never quite gels.
That said, it's still worth a watch just for
one particularly memorable and bizarre plot
twist.
If you want to see Matthew McConaughey and
Anne Hathaway work their way through some
truly strange material, Serenity is a good
way to do it.
After Hathaway's character asks her ex-husband,
played by McConaughey, to murder her current
husband, he wrestles with the idea, and you'll
probably think you know where the plot is
going from there.
Fun fact: you don't!
When the twist arrives, odds are pretty good
that you'll find it just doesn't work that well.
But man, does it try.
Serenity really swings for the fences, and
many of the bizarre plot twists further confuse
things rather than clearing them up.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.